hallo hallo n ich bin Marvin vielleicht
hast mich das ein andere Mal schon auf
Twitter oder Facebook gesehen na ja
jedenfalls würde ich gerne wissen warum
du warum ihr nur in Discus auftretet und
nicht in normalen Konzert wie andere
könstler auch ich würde mich Antwort
sehr freuen und bis dahin Ciao ja also
vieles hat damit zu tun dass wir in
Clubs auftreten ist weil wir natürlich
danzmusik machen und da findet das
einfach statt wir sind wirklich Teil der
partyzene noch und hoffe auch immer
dabei zu bleiben dass man wir machen
natürlich auch große Hallen auch mal
oder große Open Airs und so weiter das
gehört natürlich auch dazu aber man muss
natürlich auch das Publikum kriegen also
es ist natürlich nicht einfach dass oh
ich habe heute Lust vor 20.000 Menschen
aufzutreten diese 20.000 Menschen muss
natürlich auch geben die sagen ich kaufe
eine Karte um kaskada zu sehen ist
natürlich auch nicht immer der Fall aber
ganz ehrlich wir haben unheimlich viele
tolle Fans so wie du auch und komm
einfach zu uns in den Club und dann
feiern wir
zusammen